[Music]  Jesus Christ our Lord and Savior  excellent the American flag baseball's  my favorite sport  ferrets for Cecil is my favorite sport  also known as the Stars and Stripes  Jesus Christ our Lord and Savior  excellent now for something new this is  a national holiday called Thanksgiving  on the fourth Thursday of every November  families feast and think about what  they're thankful for which one's said  daddy do I have a daddy of course you do  dr. Vogel balm filling does that mean  you're my mommy sure I can be your mommy  so you love me I do  and you'll always take care of me always  it's okay we'll take care of her just  like the others today we had another  incident but this time this subject was  not driven by anger but by something  else altogether  I told dr. Vogel Baum that the subject  was obviously suffering from isolation  adduce depression but he didn't respond  he just told me to find another tutor  [Music]  you  you